toujours au chapitre des informations
générales le juge d'instruction chargé
de l'enquêté sur la mort du petit
grégory a rejeté tout à l'heure la
demande de mise en liberté du principal
inculpé de cette affaire bernard laroche
le magistrat devait prendre sa décision
aujourd'hui
au terme des cinq jours prévu par la loi
c'est donc le début d'une nouvelle phase
de l'action judiciaire nous retrouvons
sur place à epinal paul lefèvre la
décision du juge jean michel lambert
découle en fait de la logique du dossier
en accordant la mise en liberté le juge
aurait d'une certaine manière et en
fonction du contexte de la faire reconnu
que les charges contre bernard laroche
n'était pas suffisante pour justifier le
maintien en détention décision qui soit
également apparue à tort ou à raison
comme un camouflet de l' enquête des
gendarmes
le pourvoi fort probable de la défense
de bernard laroche devant la chambre
d'accusation de nancy présente en fait
deux avantages le premier faire soupesée
par les magistrats de la cour d'appel de
nancy
la valeur des charges réunies contre
l'inculpé en somme
mettre le dossier à plat voire
véritablement ce qu'il ya dedans second
avantage et les pas mince donner aux
juges un mois de répit le délai d'appel
pour réunir d'autres indices par exemple
découvrir des complices recevoir le
résultat d'une importante et nouvelles
expertises une pièce déterminante est à
l'étude en allemagne où enfin utiliser
une nouvelle piste vers un nouveau
suspect conséquence directe de ce répit
le départ de la presse qui pèse lourd
sur l' enquête depuis le début et
l'accalmie dans les esprits qui en ont
bien besoin